We want to continue to focus on the story
and the developments
of the detained American journalist
Evan Gershkovich,
who is appealing his arrest in Russia.
According to Russian state media.
The Wall Street
Journal reporter is being held in prison
in Russia,
where they hold most espionage suspects.
American detainee Paul
Whelan was also held there before
he was sent to a Russian penal colony.
Evan faces up to 20 years in prison
on these espionage charges.
His parents fled the Soviet Union
His colleagues say
he fell in love with Russia,
with its culture, with its language.
He made Moscow his second home.
He also worked
to hold the Kremlin accountable.
No longer is Russia fighting Ukraine,
but the whole West,
nothing that might even be taken
as a sign of dissent is allowed in Russia
right now.
It's massively early to say Russia's
you know, a dying power.
They are worried,
extremely worried about what
I think
everybody has seen
as an increasingly erratic government
in Moscow.
Well, friends and colleagues
are calling, of course, for his release,
as well as his family.
Pyotr Souers
is a Russian affairs
reporter for The Guardian.
And here's what he writes about Evan.
Quote, He left a comfortable job
at The New York Times
to fulfill
his longtime dream of working
as a reporter in Moscow.
He wanted to be on the ground.
He told me later
where the action happens.
And Peter Sauer joins me now.
Thank you so much for being here.
I'm so glad because,
you know, Evan,
we just saw videos of him
and we read his remarkable reporting
and we know his passion for Russia.
But can you just tell us about him,
the man?
Yeah,
I just want the world to know
what kind of guy avenues.
And he is
the nicest, smartest, most honest guy
I've probably ever met.
You know, and it's really shocking.
What's going on right now with him
and with his arrest.
We don't know a lot about the conditions
he's under.
We do know the jail he's at,
which is the fourth of a prison,
and that's where Wheeling was held.
An official
at that prison described him
as being cheerful
and making a lot of jokes.
Even in these conditions.
Does that sound like your friend?
No, that sounds exactly like Ivan.
You know, he had this infectious smile.
He that's why
he was such a good journalist as well.
He made everyone feel at ease.
Both friends and colleagues
and people he was interviewing.
And yeah, it did give me some sort of
gave a smile on my face
to hear that he's cracking jokes
being himself.
But, of course, he should not be in jail.
What why did he want to be a journalist
so much?
And why did he want to be in Russia?
Doing that journalism in this moment?
Yeah, Ivan was an all-American kid.
You know, he grew up in Jersey,
captained his
high school soccer team
but because of his parents
who were Soviet
emigres,
he always had this sort of fascination
for Russia and for the region.
So when he got the chance,
he took the job in Moscow
and, you know, right away
used his understanding of Moscow
and of Russia to show the world
what was going on
and how the country was changing
You know,
this morning I was reading Nicholas.
Daniel also,
of course,
is the only other journalist before Evan,
what's been since his arrest
on espionage charges in 1986. Right.
And he was held there for so long.
Here's what he writes
in the Wall Street Journal this morning.
Reporting in Russia has always been risky
He goes on to say,
We need to protect and honor
the bravery
of foreign
correspondents, photographers,
stringers all over the world
reporting in difficult
and dangerous circumstances
and to my fellow Russia correspondent
Evan Herskovitz.
Courage. Courage.
What do you think
the powerful words
Ivan will need to have a lost
triangle of courage?
I know he's strong,
but we need to keep on supporting him.
You know, he took the decision.
He thought it was his duty
to keep on reporting
out of Russia,
to let the world know
what was going on in the country.
You know, it was very important decision.
But now I think it's our duty
to really
let the world know what's going on with
its conditions.
His case
is, you know, it's a very,
very important case for the world.
And when he was arrested,
he was reporting in Siberia, talking
to average
Russians about the war in Ukraine.
Did he ever talk to you about the danger?
Did he feel like this was a risk for him?
You know, we talked every day.
I mean, we talked 2 hours
before his arrest.
We just exchanged text.
And, of course, it's
something you talk about,
you know, should I still be here?
Is this is this the right place to be?
But he felt
you know,
no one benefits
from Russia being a black box.
You know, you need
you needed to explain the story.
You always told me.
I want to get the story right.
He was an accredited journalist
from the Foreign Ministry.
So you had all the right to be there.
He was just doing his job, you know?
Yeah. Well.
Such a valuable and invaluable job,
I should say, for the world
and the reporting you do as well.
Pyotr, thank you very much
for the work
you do for sharing a bit with us
about your friend Eva.
And we are all thinking about him
and hoping that they can bring him home.
Thank you.